[Music]
juggalo march on washington
as you may or may not know the fbi has
designated them a criminal gang
honestly it happened so long ago i
thought that whole thing blew over but
apparently it didn't
and uh people so we're here uh what's
your name
my name is ross waldner russ ross right
all right cool uh we got a couple
questions just want to ask people so
of course for those that aren't familiar
with juggalos can you give us a quick
rundown
uh juggalos are mostly his uh insane
clown posse and psychopathic records
fans uh they like uh they're the rap
uh hardcore metal style
music and they're just basically music
fans of that genre
and uh the fbi is alleging that icp are
a criminal organization is that true
uh they are uh they did submit a
criminal index or security threat index
and they did say that juggalos are one
of the security threat groups
and it's kind of messed up so they're
are they
are they gang or not no sir we are not
organized
enough to be a gang we're not pulling
our money into some giant
criminal enterprise or anything like
that uh there are maybe some people who
have been in a gang
uh who were juggalos but that's their
deal
uh basically my problem is
i live in some neighborhoods i have
where there are gang presence
and maybe uh somebody would say i'm a
rival gangster and shoot me that would
be messed up
to me um
so that's uh you know that's kind of
messed up so you guys aren't involved in
like human trafficking
or like drug cartels or bombing judges
and
like texas none of that's happening
right uh
you know the one no no
just go with no probably no you i i have
to say i am glad i'm not your attorney
um now as now if the juggalos were a
gang
how would they stack up against la cosa
nosho or the yakuza
[Music]
uh we would the yakuza are way more
organized than
us they would uh probably uh cut us up
man
uh samurai swords yeah
and that's basically the problem uh i'm
scared of the yakuza
uh come and kill me i'm actually
japanese part japanese and hey
if he joins the juggalos and not the
yakuza he's a race trader yeah
basically yeah i have a question um how
do you feel about president trump
sorry compromising with the democrats
i have no problem with him compromising
with the democrats
uh i think trump had to do what he had
to do
uh with that you know i think
sometimes he says some things to appeal
to his base
that he you know whatever he has to do
it but we got to give the president a
chance at some point
uh because he is he kind of is an
outsider
uh you know kind of like eeo he's the
trump card baby
all right i got another question do
magnets affect the climate and what role
did they play in the recent hurricane
season
they may have i have no idea i'm not a
scientist
uh but yes uh global warming i think is
kind
uh is uh in magnetism the polar magazine
it's gonna it i think it's real person
now uh what is your position regarding
corn subsidies that keep products like
faygo affordable for the working class
it's i'm fine with it i'm not gonna cry
if they went away
uh but yes uh the working club give them
a break
but uh yeah sure are juggalos the last
hope for western civilization
they are not the last hope but maybe the
but one of the last
house that's fair
also uh quick question do you have any
ketamine uh
no not right now um i i you know
maybe keep it legal and maybe talk
bottle of robot dozen
well i mean it is legal just for cats um
did you find riddle box to be too
preachy
riddle box not at all that was uh
that was a kind of uh old school album
by my standards
uh so no
will there ever be a collaboration
between icp and sam hyde
i don't know who sammod is he's uh he's
an indie rapper he goes by the name zany
tanner
hey dude do it now um i have a question
this is a little more serious now
are juggalos and the alt-right mutually
exclusive
no they're not mutually exclusive but
they are not definitely the same thing
now you see i have heard i just want to
point out i've heard more open-minded
rationaled responses from the juggalos
than i did at the
other rally today so giving you guys
props if you could pick any republican
to join the juggalos who would it be
ron paul maybe uh he'd be cool uh i'm
like
he has a libertarian uh you know you
stick up for your liberties
uh so you know he'd be a viable
candidate
uh on the other side bernie sanders he i
identify with him too
a little bit i feel like bernie would
make a good juggalo yes too
yes all right i got two more quick
questions one are traps gay
a little bit okay that's a fair fair
answer and the last question
with brexit the rise of trump and the
inevitable victory of kid rock
is there a shaggy too dope congressional
term uh on the horizon
absolutely i love it ross thank you so
much for joining us we do have a present
for you
a little parting gift for our folks
faygo moon miss blue we came from north
carolina with these
just for folks that want to talk with us
and uh
thank you sir i am uh i'm making it very
known that i'm actually standing with
these guys
they're uh smoke [ __ ] know how to
party we're gonna get one more people
we'll be back soon
you